what can i do for you what do you got
for me right now
wow um i stumbled across your compton
just recently
and um man i'll tell you i i was
blessed i had a lot of opportunities uh
because
my parents you know just many things
alike so
i had opportunities in context i was
doing great in business
all this stuff but the only side that
sucked
was with women i would find myself just
on dating apps
hours up two three hours a day and then
i had my business making
um when i first started my business
six figures and then i would just go
back like i would shrink and then be on
dating apps
oh it's terrible hours on instagram just
searching girls
and i didn't know you know why i sucked
with a woman man i found your content
and i was a little bit not sure
watch more videos man i'll say this
thank you like
what you're doing is just changing lives
it's insane
i'm free right now redfield 100
you're welcome okay so what are you
stuck on or is this just a big thank you
uh no i just just want to say thank you
man um i'm not actually chasing a woman
right now you know what he said
uh the last guy on the call single mom
40 year old
man that's that's bad so 28 year old
dating a woman it's like 20 years
younger well not 20 years but you know
you get the point almost 15 years older
yeah yeah that's crazy so uh just uh
one question um i kind of feel inside
that you know i have my business
i don't really worry about money now i
live in mexico
and um should i just kind of
just on the side search for a girl just
like that for later on
how old are you uh 26 next month be 24.
yeah you shouldn't be in a monogamous
long-term relationship in your 20s dude
okay that's like the growth phase it's
like letting the ground work for your
life you're already making a lot of
money
you're the founder of the business like
you're the entrepreneur behind it all
uh it's a family business and i got my
own stuff out
okay good good so you know work on
building that up i'm not saying don't
date women i'm not saying
you know don't expose yourself but just
don't
don't make the goal finding a girlfriend
or a wife
you probably get some cultural pressure
yeah you know there's obviously going to
be
you know religion and culture find a
good girl and settle down and why don't
you have some kids and blah blah blah
you got lots of time to do that you're
not in the same timeline as women
um this is a different time than what it
was you know from your parents age and
your grandparents age
um you've got plenty of time you know
wait till you're 30.
okay and date her for a good couple of
years to see what she's made of
like don't just okay i found a good one
it's been a good year
let's plan the wedding and get
everything going and and do this
date her for a good couple of years two
years see what she's really made of let
stress get applied to the relationships
see how she responds to it does she
freak out can she handle it properly
right look for good strong indicators
like that
okay uh i have one question um
this obviously i i know you know what
are you going to say but
um what do you what do you think on you
know this whole
russian ukrainian dating kind of woman
yeah i've covered that before there's a
lot of guys that think that
if they like the grass is greener on the
other side of the fence sort of thing
yeah well you know i've read that
you know don't date uh american woman
because
the whole feminist movement and you know
they don't care about gender roles that
kind of stuff
and women in ukraine and russia they're
feminine and
but i also heard guys say you know
they're going to scam you they just want
your money or
the visa stuff like that so i'm really
well there's that component to it too
and it's true
it doesn't matter if it's colombian
venezuelan russia it doesn't matter dude
it's like the grass is not greener on
the other side of the fence the grass is
greener where you water and fertilize it
where you're standing
okay so if you i mean if you have a
thing for eastern european women
so let's put it to that if you have a
thing for them then
i would say fine you know then date
those kind of women if you you know if
you find them attractive but
every culture has a different thing
about them that you gotta understand
like eastern european
women are very very difficult to manage
on a long-term basis they've got very
high demands
and when you bring somebody from a
foreign country to your country
um they're gonna get domesticated within
the next year to two years tops so
whatever happens in
that culture they're gonna start to look
around
i mean it's part of the reason why um
eddie murphy added that joke to his uh
stand up back in the 80s i can't
remember if it was delirious or raw
but unfufu the zebra chick that he
brought back and if you haven't seen the
stand up you know you gotta
go watch the clip half eddie right
within
a year or two and that was in the 80s it
was recognized back then
that was common ground nothing's changed
it's just gotten worse you're not going
to get better women going to a different
country
okay you're going to get different
cultural you get different looks
european women are different from asian
women from venezuelan women
they look slightly different they might
have different cultural values yeah they
might be more feminine
but here's the thing this is where most
guys go wrong they'll just import them
and they think oh i brought this
feminine woman
or everything will be fine but you still
have to have rock solid frame
you just can't rest on the laurels of
okay i got a foreign bride everything's
going to be good we're done
you still have to have rock solid frame
and you still have to date her for a
good couple years before you wipe her up
if that's what you're planning to do you
know to have kids and stuff like that
slow it down you know make sure it's not
like a whirlwind let's get this done in
the next six to 12 months it's no
there's still a two-year vetting period
see what she's made out of
okay so two years two years minimum
um if you don't catch the earlier
episodes of the before the train wreck
sean smith wrote this book he used to
run the show with me you should read it
and he talks about that
in his book from his clinical practice
okay yeah because
for example just one thing i i haven't
hit the gym in
years part of it is just i i've been
all my time devoted into my business and
just
just kind of like look like look at my
arms i'm not
i'm not it's i'm skinny yeah yeah yeah
i'm like so
i i i wanna i wanna think i have to work
more on that that
um you know going back and chasing a
woman and
i would i would spend more time on
fit like physical self-care whether it's
lifting weights get into some kind of
combat sport have you read my book
no i just bought it okay good um because
i cover stuff like that in the book but
do something for self-care so that you
create the optics of masculinity and
strength
because it's one thing to try to lead a
woman and to have her enter your frame
whether you import her from russia or if
you
you know get with a mexican girl or
anything like that it's one thing to try
to lead her
and have her in your frame it's much
much easier if you look the part too
right if you're strong if you have broad
shoulders narrow away six-pack abs right
like you take care
you know you've got combat skills you
know how to beat the crap out of
somebody if the knee
you know is called upon you if you get
into a difficult situation
women will enter the frame of a guy like
that and say yes more often
to him if he looks more of the part sure
you can set that all aside
and you can have rock solid game and you
can you know try to run that
relationship
but without looking the part it's going
to be harder for you man
you know it's funny you mentioned that
because what i have seen is
um with the girls that i have gone out
and and
some not all but they know i'm doing
well and a lot of times
the money that i'm making it's just it
doesn't make the cut likes no
i i i have seen this not enough when
they see well he has
this part boiled down but this other
parts
i'm not so sure how much how much money
do you make on an annual basis in usd
roughly uh about 600 000
on an annual basis that's what you pay
yourself yeah
yeah just that's profit you make more
than enough money dude
you make plenty of money there's like
you're probably in the top one percent
of all
income earners in all of mexico at that
rate right yes
yes okay so money's not the problem for
you you know for you it's things like
game it's like the optics of masculinity
you know it's understanding and actually
applying the red pill to your real life
on a day-to-day basis
those are the things that matters and
here's the other thing too guys like you
are a target
for manipulative women you've got to be
very very careful because as soon as a
chick hears oh this guy carlos makes 600
000 usd a year in a country like mexico
where that goes really far
women will act that's why i tell guys
give it a couple of years see what she's
really made of see if she's
really in your frame because it's easy
for them to act for six or 12 months to
get the ring and get the wedding
do it for two years straight that's a
lot harder
right so guys like you got to be careful
because you know if you left the wrong
chick in your life and she's got mental
disorders
and you know you get married and have
kids dude guys like you can get
destroyed
in the family court system i don't know
what it's like exactly in mexico but
it's probably pro you know pretty
similar to what it is in u.s and canada
oh it's fat
it's bad yeah and my uncle his
uh his wife just on him and the
biggest thing for you right now carlos
is you need to
understand game and red pill dynamics
to a t to protect yourself
okay it is it is probably the most
important thing i mean you know beyond
you know the optics of masculinity and
strength and game and you know
significance and all that sort of stuff
but you got to be really really careful
man because if you get bamboozled by
some hot check
but you know just you know you let her
in your life and all of a sudden
you think oh this girl just gets me you
know all these other girls never really
got me before but this one actually
understands me for a change
you got to be super careful with that so
if you take anything away from this
conversation
date for two years before you do
anything with them okay
okay yeah oh all right i'll read my book
and read sean's book too because that'll
really help you out
with whatever i'll take this question
what's that
can you put it on the screen so i'll
take a quick screenshot it's it's called
the tactical guide to women
okay got it there you go
all right well let me know how it works
out for you man you know come back a few
months and let me know how you're doing
all right
man thank you all right see you later
brother peace
you